très intéressant new marais tekintamgac
qu'un vieux poème peut être une chanson
par les soirs bleu d'été j'irai dans
l'est santé beau puis côté par les
blessures et les rebelles de l'est très
peur choisir man ray
fraîcheur à mes pieds le rituel a serait
le vent fait nhiêm internet
[Musique]
penser
et l'amour infini
le voir dans l'âme
j'irai loin bien
com
et si m
par la nature eux comme avec une femme
[Musique]
c'est libre de droit suivons les
rivières gard dont les torrents reste 11
en colère soyons vigilants tous les
films non n'oublions jamais pour vous de
la vie au foot
au bout d'une
et doucement
l'aube revient quand même et même pâle
le jour se lève encore tu verras étonné
on reprend le corps à corps allons-y
maintenant soleil
[Musique]
bonjour cela
longtemps
[Musique]
ces barbares par 20
mais ce qui a fait notre chanson ça tu
leur juste part
je crois que c'était un poème du bruit
mais ça poèmes parce que je les ai reçus
en fac et quand je les appelais j'ai dit
barbara j'ai fait une musique sur ton
poème elle m'a dit mais attends tu
plaisantes écoute pas mes disques avec
les jeunes fait un truc well avait déjà
fait un truc tu verra le jour se lève
encore j'étais petit et non via prè je
vais montrer m'a dit bon allez prends la
prends trop classe-c et pendant deux
semaines elle m'appelait tous les genres
le musée l'aigle noir tu connais change
pas la musique
j'en fais une autre une autre d'accord
il qu'à ce jeu en petit
et harry
breton beauté à paris c'est fait ça fait
cap et de marc touret pierre cazé des
jambes ça m'est égal
[Musique]
rien n'égale fabien distance aviator
milan reste assez pour moi il en reste
assez
c'est demain j'aurai toujours un peu
d'air
un petit filet de vie
dans l'oeil
peu de plaisir lumière
bien beau région [ __ ] je me suis dit
que j'allais le dire dans les yeux
ok
[Musique]
que
le pas
je
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
1 1
pas du tout
que
les beatles
non
à
[Musique]
e
ouais c'était bien ça
l'étape
[Musique]
pitau
et cela
[Musique]
t
oui
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]
/
oui
[Musique]
et refaire
what you
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoique
merci
le doigt sur nous
[Musique]
créée
non
[Musique]
wade
non
tank est fait
[Musique]
non
c'est finalement 6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça
est-ce pêche
[Musique]
g
e
[Musique]
chez
chercheur
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es là
[Musique]
m
ouais c'est la guitare à dd vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir
non je ne savais pas moi bah il est
pétri de talents d'acteurs réalisateurs
non mais là tu ressens et aux non je
savais pas et encore tu n'as pas lu 7
films de boules rappelle un peu
d'enfants et l'oiseau
[Musique]
notez
là
[Musique]
et les slovènes
et
[Musique]
m
si m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui vient d'où vient de loin
ce qui
il tient jamais les âmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pied
perdu
ce qu'on a cru
vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit
le mois
pas
soit
[Musique]
le mois le toit
il
saleh
[Musique]
et
m
oui
la mairie
ce mois
et
cette année
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais quand deux
ça
[Musique]
et eux
[Applaudissements]
là
chan
outil
[Musique]
pieds nus
on n ira pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
andrew g
ce qui suit
r d
pas trop foulé le temps
tu es
et
[Musique]
mais
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini
on m'a pas dit au revoir comme sur le
quai d'une gare
j'te dis seulement bonjour les gars
alors
[Musique]
ce signe
aujourd'hui
enfin c'est le moment
j'ai même peut-être rappelé m
je ne
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux